so we have a function f of X graphed
right over here then we have a bunch of
statements about the limit of f of X as
X approaches different values and what I
want to do is figure out which of these
statements are true and which of these
are false so let's look at this first
statement limit of f of X as X
approaches 1 from the positive direction
is equal to 0 so is this true or false
so let's look at it so we're talking
about as X approaches 1 from the
positive direction so from for values
greater than 1 so as X approaches 1 from
the positive direction what is f of X
well when X is let's say 1 and 1/2 f of
X is up here as X gets closer and closer
to 1 f of X stays right at 1 so as we
pro as X approaches 1 from the positive
direction it looks like the limit of X
or it looks like the limit of f of X as
X approaches 1 from the positive
direction isn't a 0 it looks like it is
1 so this is not this is not true this
would be true if instead of saying from
the positive direction we said from the
negative direction from the negative
direction the function really does look
like it is a the value of the function
really does look like it is approaching
0 for approaching 1 from the negative
direction when X is right over here this
is f of X when X is right over here this
is f of X when X is right over here this
is f of X and we see that the value of f
of X seems to get closer and closer to 0
so this would only be true if we were
approaching from the negative direction
next question limit of f of X as X
approaches 0 from the negative direction
is the same as limit of f of X as X
approaches 0 from the positive direction
is this statement true well let's look
our function f of X as we approach 0
from the negative direction
let me just in a new color as we
approach 0 from the negative direction
so right over here this is our value of
f of X then as we get closer this is our
value of f of X as we get even closer
this is our value of f of X so it seems
from the negative direction like it is
approaching positive 1 from the positive
direction when X is greater than 0
oh let's try it out so if like say X is
1/2 this is our f of X if X is let's say
1/4 this is our f of X if X is just
barely larger than 0 this is our f of X
so it also seems to be approaching f of
X f of X is equal to 1 so this looks
true they both seem to be approaching
the limit of 1 the limit here is 1 so
this is absolutely true now let's look
at this statement the limit of f of X as
X approaches 0 from the negative
direction is equal to 1 well we've
already thought about that
the limit of f of X as X approaches from
the negative direction as 0 the limit of
f of X as X approaches 0 from the
negative direction we see that we're
getting closer and closer to 1 as X gets
closer and close to 0
f of X gets closer and closer to 1 so
this is also true limit of f of X as X
approaches 0 exists well it definitely
exists we've already established that
it's equal to 1 so that's true now the
limit of f of X as X approaches 1 exists
is that true well we already saw that
when we're approaching 1 from the
positive direction the limit seems to be
approaching 1 we get when x is 1 and 1/2
f of X is 1 when X is a little bit more
than 1 it's 1 so it seems like we're
getting closer and closer to 1 so let me
write that on the limit of f of X as X
as X approaches 1 from the positive
direction is equal to 1 and now what's
the limit the limit of f of X as X
approaches 1 from the negative direction
well here this is our f of X here this
is our f of X it seems like our f of X
is getting closer and closer to 0 when
we approach 1 from values less than 1 so
over here is equals 0 so the limit from
the right hand side is a different value
than the limit from the left hand side
then the villa the limit does not exist
so this is this is not this is not true
now finally the limit of f of X as X
approaches one point five is equal to
one so right over here so everything
we've been dealing with so far we've
always looked at points of discontinuity
or points where maybe the function isn't
quite defined but here this is kind of a
plain vanilla point
X is equal to 1.5 that's maybe right
over here this is f of 1.5 that right
over there is the point well this is the
value F of 1.5 we could say F of we
could see that F of 1.5 is equal to one
that this right here is the point 1
point 5 comma 1 and if we approach it
from the from the left hand side from
values less than it it's 1 the limit
seems to be 1 when we approach from the
right hand side the limit seems to be 1
so this is a pretty straightforward
thing the graph is continuous right
there and so really if we just
substitute at that point or we just look
at the graph the limit is the value of
the function there you don't have to
have a function be undefined in order to
find a limit there so it is indeed the
case that the limit of f of X as X
approaches 1 point 5 is equal to 1